aucun d'entre nous ne peut être
insensible à la voie que nous venons
d'entendre aucun français
aucune française quelques étés depuis
les désillusions ne peut oublier l'appel
du 18 juin
la gloire des grands souvenirs ne peut
être abolie mais une élection
présidentielle ne peut pas être une
commémoration
elle est une décision la vôtre pour
l'avenir pour sept ans et bien davantage
nous n'avons donc pas à renier
l'histoire ni à nous enfermer dans le
passé de cette histoire
nous avons plutôt à nous y adosser pour
prendre la mesure de la grandeur
française est donnée au peuple français
c'est une nouvelle marche vers l'avenir
[Musique]
cet avenir est désormais assuré la
relève est prête c'est je crois la
grande révélation de la campagne
électorale qui s'achève
vous ne redoutez plus l'après gaullisme
vous ne redoutez plus le vide ou le trop
plein et vous connaissez les grands
objectifs qui seront les nôtres bâtir
l'europe marché résolument en défendant
pied à pied les intérêts français
mais avancer vers les états unis
d'europe créer la prospérité la faire
partager à tous les français et d'abord
aux plus humbles ali mais nos régions
faire une france généreuse et social ces
objectifs sont six aces essentielle si
évident que je suis convaincu que si
vous me portier à la présidence de la
république il prouverait leur accord au
sein du parlement français
ou sinon une nouvelle majorité les
porterait dans la stabilité
par conséquent la succession est
désormais possible sans heurt sans
transition sans à-coups dans l'ordre
dans le calme
saisissons cette occasion qui peut ne
pas se représenter et qui est notre
chance commune pour construire notre
avenir
certains disent encore un peu de temps
plus tard
mais pourquoi si le général de gaulle
après une longue hésitation s'est
finalement décidé à se représenter
c'est probablement parce qu'il sait
convaincus qu'aucun homme politique peut
être même dans son entourage ne pourrait
faire admettre au peuple français
une politique qui n'est plus conforme
aux aspirations des français parce qu
elle barre la route de l'europe parce
qu'elle compromet nos alliances
parce qu'elle ne fait pas avancer
suffisamment le progrès social et
économique
mais si le général de gaulle fait appel
à sa légende pour tenter de maintenir et
d'imposer encore cette politique c'est
pour nous une raison de plus de la
combattre et c'est la raison de notre
candidature
10 ferrer l'échéance qui est inéluctable
accordé un sursis pourquoi pour cumuler
les retards que nous avons déjà constaté
et dont nous souffrons tous par rapport
aux autres pays du marché commun mettre
en péril les dernières chances qui nous
reste de sauver l'europe unie et croyez
vous que la succession au plan intérieur
français serait plus facile dans
quelques mois ou dans quelques années je
suis pour ma part convaincu
au contraire les difficultés les
rivalités ne pourront que se développer
et aggraver la situation
nous avons au contraire dimanche
prochain la possibilité de nous
prononcer avec un horizon calme et sans
qu'aucun orages politique grave nous
menacent nous pouvons donc penser à
notre avenir et le construire ce qui se
passe ce que vous sentez sais que
l'histoire est en train de tourner le
temps de la tragédie le temps de la
guerre et de l'après guerre est terminée
c'est révolu voici maintenant que
s'ouvre une période nouvelle pour des
horizons nouveaux pour une génération
nouvelle qui doit se mettre en mouvement
assurer la relève assurée dans l'ordre
dans le calme dans la continuité la
succession de nos affaires mais bien
entendu nous aurons des efforts à
déployer
car la paix c'est aussi l'effort mais
pour construire pour bâtir le bonheur
des hommes encore faut-il que nous ayons
le courage de nous rassembler de briser
les vieux clivages du passé de surmonter
des querelles périmés et de se forger
ensemble
la grande force démocrate social et
européenne sur laquelle reposera la
majorité et la stabilité politique de
demain voilà les possibilités qui nous
sont offertes à il faut effacer toutes
les frontières
non seulement celle qui sépare les
nations mais les frontières intérieures
au dedans de nos consciences
il faut que les chrétiens et ceux qui ne
le sont pas
il faut que les français et les
françaises de toute religion de toute
philosophie se rassemblent convergent
vers un humanisme social non pas qu'ils
abandonnent leurs convictions au
contraire ils doivent se nourrir les uns
les autres de leur foi et de ce qui est
pour eux la vérité mais ils doivent se
rejoindre au plan de l'action pour
donner à la france des temps modernes un
élan nouveau les landes une france
fraternelle pacifie généreuse
la voilà la vraie grandeur celle du
mieux-être des hommes dans
l'épanouissement des libertés
vive la france et vive la république
[Musique]